Who's the fastest man alive?
Sanic?
Supaman?
Flesh?
No... It can't be
Keemstar.
He's the fastest
I need to be faster.
How can he be so fast?
*Keemstar: IM FAST AS FUCK*
There must be an answer
*Keemstar in the background saying some bullshit*
Dammit!
Who is the quickest?
Who is behind this equation..
Who is the quickest one?
2,000 mph
Sanic
2,500 mph, Supaman
Flesh at 3,000 mph
All the calculations are correct
DJ KILLER KEEMSTAR
He's fast as fuck, booii
How can I be so fast with these legs?
They're not nearly fast enough. (but sexy af)
*What's that papa poods?*
Scooter-kun!?
I'm fast as fuck, boi
Imma make you the fastest bitch alive
You faster den Keemstarr
Impossible!
No one can be faster than...Killer Keem!
I will prove to you that me and my friends can make it happen!
Working together, using the powers of friendship and wheels <3
We are strong!
Ok...Ok Scooter-sama (fuckin' decide who ure talkin' to mate!) I'll go with you.
*Epic montage music plays.*
That's speed test #1, Scooter-sama (OK let's stick with sama then)
*Pewds exercising wit some tricks*
This the only way I can go fast enough.
If I don't make it back alive (don't say that poods :<)
Make sure you sub to Keemstar (I'll be damned)
*Poods rolling awaaay*
MORE EPICNESS PLZ
*INTENSE SA(TA)NIC MUSIC
THAT'S RIGHT!
*Poods sensei showing us the finest tricks!*
You know I'm fast but my friends is faster.
Yeah? Why don't you introduce me?
You ever seen these?
Rollerblades without da shoes *CLAK*
I got shoes, tho
So it's fine (BE CAREFUL PAPA POODS)
*fails miserably*
*and fails again...*
*POODS 1 - 0 LIFE*
*boops camera*
*laughs* Jesus!
Dude I was killing it!
I went real fast..
But not nearly fast enough.
*Throws roller blades to dumpster*
*RIP roller blades*
*gotta go fast (͡ ͡° ͜ つ ͡͡°) *
*Epic bike drift*
Not fast...
ENUFF
*throws down the bike and proceeds to assault it*
*FINISH HIM*
*good bye wood bike*
*say hello to the rollerblades*
This is the one.
*the hell is this?*
Fast...
*trys to gain balance*
...As Fuck.
This is the one thats going to take me back to the future.
*some friendly help*
*SAY HI TO MARTY AND DOC FOR ME!*
(HOLY SHIT ಠoಠ )
(IT WORKED)
(PEWDS WHERE ARE YOU??!!)
(Oh shit you're back)
I've returned
but wait
theres more from the time space conti..n..u...um..
*box drops down from out of shot by sponsor eagle*
Thank you sponsor space eeeeagle!
(IM DEAFF)
Epic film making.
So we're gonna unbox last month's theme
Which is "Futuristic"
Y'all ready but wait lootcrate changes theme every month the 19th.
Make sure you order before the 19th to get August's theme "Anti-hero".
Go to lootcrate.com/pewds enter the code "pewds"
You get 10% off.
(I've heard this shit so many times I swear I know it by heart now)
*Pewds' Mating Call*
Mega Man!
Okay.. Oh! Which one am I gonna get?
Which one do you want, Michael?
Michael: "Meega Man :<"
Oh, you want Mega Man?
Aww you want Mega Man? C'mon.
Oh my god.
Michael thinking: I swear if he's fooling me...
*laughs*
ha.. no..  AYEEEEEE!
I guess it's Mega Man.
Is this Mega-?
It is :D
Why is he orange?
That is... That is pretty kawaii sugoi,
am I right?
It's actually pretty cool. I really like it, it's a good design.
Michael you want this?
Michael: Yeaah!
Michael: OW
Take the box.
*Throws box*
*IM FINE BUT ACTUALLY NOT PLS HELP ME YOUTUBE #SaveMichael*
I don't know what this is, I just know it's Rick and Morty, but if you know what it is let me know in the comments.
Are you guys fans of The Simpsons?
Cause it's my favorite cartoon
and I LOVE the spaceship
the Millenium Falcon
Ohhh here we go
(you can do it pewds)
*clak*
HEEYYY :D
We just started doing this studio so we have a shelf now, and we need a bunch of stuff in
Lootcrate is perfect for that
Okay this is weird. This is the first time I actually don't know what it is.
I mean, it says USS Enterprise so I know its Star Wars
but star fleet.. I don't know
I don't know why like it's this thing
Let me know in the comments if you know what Star Wars this is from.
HEYY!
There's another comicbook
it's 4001AD
Oh dude this is sick.
And finally, as well, a "Peace be with you" from... what's that a... from Battle Star Galactica
Okay! So we have our shelf, it's really nice
I like these little figurines
Check out Lootcrate you get 10% off if you use the link in the description
lootcrate.com/pewds, enter the code "pewds" AND it supports the show and I really appreciate it, it really means a lot.
and you get a good offer on cool shit like this.
*More epic song*
That was fast, but it was only 88 mph.
And I gotta go, at least...
FAST AS FUCK.
Oh, oh. Oh no. Oh no. Oh no. Oh.
That was my only shot.
There is one last hope, PewDiePie.
Tell me
I'll do anything.
ROBO-BITCH
That sounds awesome.
Where is it?
There.
Oh...
*badass music plays*
*That's what it is to be an adult my child*
*badass music continues*
*Keemstar Vine Recreation*
Do you have any idea how fast I am?
I'm fast as fuck, boi!